[Music]
and let it out news let it out
submit by Taco Bell or del Taco how
about I like both I'll go down I've ever
had the chicken soft tacos it's pretty
good
Taco Bell keeps you guessing man even
know what they're doing next all of a
sudden you go there and it's like hey
try the new nacho loaded griller and
you're like what does that [ __ ] is that
they always keep next-level things right
all the way up it's like try a new taco
burrito and you're like what the [ __ ] is
a taco burrito the new not you read over
eateth deluxe they tried the donto
phrase yeah the [ __ ] breath
Chacho fries nacho have you tried the
nacho face said John Charles [ __ ]
sell taco no no from taco
where have you been it was like huge
whose everywhere ok jack in the gym how
that secretary is nothing that can
replace a [ __ ] wasn't called a
chalupa
I [ __ ] love chalupa snoopers are
great yeah getting gored by the way
cheesy gordita crunch at Taco Bell
forget it I'd rather be dead than
whatever Gordon Ramsay makes yeah I get
that supreme taco with a rat what [ __ ]
trash like a rat shell that's just the
best I love to lupus it's like a Mexican
croissant
you're gonna pita bread for him [ __ ]
because you know like I've been eating
who do we got it jumps on the dog [ __ ]
a lot she cut my gut my intestines I
feel like I've been eating a lot
healthier right ok cool I could have
like a cheat I could eat some [ __ ] I'll
[ __ ] eat by any like McDonald's or
fast food I get constipated like that
constipated I get constipated and and a
stomach pains because you're not getting
badges you have edges from a Big Mac I
don't care how bad it is for me what I
want it I want it like she just licked
the Hamburg when I live it away I got a
filet-o-fish I hate that [ __ ] I had mad
stomach eggs but I could give a [ __ ]
like I'm gonna show them there's
something wrong in the food I've never
gotten a stomachache and off of my dolls
yeah so if I if I eat like ramen noodles
or I don't know like some kind of like
white bread or some [ __ ] it [ __ ] up my
gut no I don't know what it's what it's
doing but here it's not ready for it
yeah I got I'm sorry they're here here's
the best taco bar del Taco cops right
there alright moving on here's here's
what you do alright there's not
don't ever look ahead you betcha I
didn't get to talk that's why so I'm
gonna talk you're gonna do the new diet
program all right you get your smoothie
right you get your hamburger you [ __ ]
bite into your hamburger you chew you
spit that out and then you drink your
smoothie while you have the taste in
your mouth I'll bet that's gonna be the
best yeah you have the food that you
shouldn't be eating that you should have
you smell and then you take a bite of
the healthy one you smell the good food
and then you take that punch
laughs as a crunch that's not the same
texture this is so expensive you guys
yeah this is very expensive I have to
buy the food that I want not to not eat
and then I have to buy the healthy food
which is way more expensive you then and
then I have to smell this will get the
taste though that's the way I just wake
up with a fat stomach gate put a big
smile on my face oh hell yeah University
hasn't solved the cry cause it for
stressed-out students of course closeted
the cry closet like in the classroom
like oh my god for your [ __ ] quiet
closet right now yeah the cry Mike if I
came into my friend's room like a homeys
room right he goes yo home we throw taco
that's my cried closet I was like cool
well get in this like a jump your ass
give you something to cry about what the
[ __ ] do you mean cry closet yeah so the
University of Utah has installed a tiny
cry closet to be for mens those crying
as Mormons it's true it's pretty [ __ ]
Salt Lake Criers like that's just the
Mormon term for a vocal booth the closet
at the University of Utah oh my god
stuffed animal [ __ ] stuffed animals
lined black this is a university yes wow
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] what you gonna do
throw something around a meeting flat
properly
throw the [ __ ] throw it [ __ ] I feel good
to know I want to do this you guys think
I'm about violence yeah yeah no why are
you here about peace
you pretty much are I'm about love now
[ __ ] Kanye taught me the way so that
[ __ ] is so they could be like this it
your what the [ __ ] just cry don't you
like to cry about your university
student you [ __ ] missed your midterm
and gotta answer some [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
you live in America you look at the top
percent of the world dude if you have a
job in America or whatever if you make
30 a year you're the top 1% of the world
you know what's a really good idea just
cry in your room what about let me tell
you something
cry in front of them make them feel
uncomfortable make eye contact yeah you
never jacked off infront of your
roommate it made me feel uncomfortable
amen it's gonna happen whether you like
it or not yeah there's nothing wrong
with crying I wish I had a crack close
at the home crying's awesome because
it's a great release nothing wrong with
crying okay but how often are you crying
that you need a crying room at school
yeah apparently like you know these
students are so stressed out with their
exams the high student loan rates and
all this [ __ ] people having bad days
getting dumped via text messages all
this [ __ ] right I was with everything
until that last part university students
are going through so much these days so
that's why this university thought that
they don't do the text they would help
the students out by installing this
crack closet and there's also rules I go
in there - [ __ ] no diddling absolutely
no discipline diddly
I'm diddling - when you go in after me
it's gonna smell something oh you can
barely fit in this closet okay it's
standing jack off easy you can leave my
self up and I stand up I feel like
you're gonna try to go and use and you
open the doors to the homeless man
inside smiling no homeless people out
it's [ __ ] up you have to knock before
entering that's the first world okay
reasonable
[Laughter]
only one person will closet at a time
that's the second role the third can you
imagine to be what does a dive in the
closet it's like a phone booth like you
gotta use the phone kind of thing yeah
yeah cuz they actually all the time
limit you can't spend more than 10
minutes in there what I will say this
man if you're going to those spots and
you need to cry I completely support you
but just be willing to know that I have
tomatoes outside what if I had this at
home then Nicki would only be able to
cry in one place and I would like that
we should get install that home cuz as
it is my whole [ __ ] house is a Christ
you should have a designated quiet area
I like this idea that's what I'm saying
because I mean there's designated nap
areas oh yeah
so I don't they make cry tears does that
mean the rest of the campus is an elk
rhizome I know right it's height and
then people are also asking like wait a
minute is this closet soundproof because
if it's not then what's the point about
the smokes the earth inside probably not
some people like nothing against God I
cried during movies all the time but my
thing is like why do you need a
designated spot for just [ __ ] cry it
where the [ __ ] you're a dude what's the
last movie you cried I cried every
single movie that [ __ ] animated movie
that just came out not to Coco Coco
right in Coco credit I'll cry in the
whole movie I cried during Moana cuz I
was so [ __ ] bored I couldn't believe
it
holy [ __ ] I cried in bacteria to the
beautiful horn I was in the beginning
I'm like this is so oh my god yeah I
never cried out of joy but I've cried
because like I was really close to my
grandma so you know when that part
towards the end I don't want to spoil it
for you but there's it there's a very
touchy part towards the end what do you
try to communicate to his grandmother
that [ __ ] got me to remind me of my
grandma and I was like mmm I cried out
your playlist panels were over dust true
I definitely cried from laughter a lot
though you know what I don't think
anyone should hold in their emotions
because it's good to let them out but
there is a time and place in the right
place as a cry room yeah so are they
saying that these students are going
through so much stress that they need us
so much I mean
being a college student studies student
sitting during finals I remember I
remember being a college student working
full time coming to school full time and
[ __ ] does get stressful I mean I mean
that that's the first time you're living
that part of your life so I can see why
people went to college and work full
time at the same yeah dude it was nuts
thank you and then um that's crazy
I quit just like a go to college so this
is the difference was um I didn't I
didn't live on campus I lived at home so
good cry in your bed yeah but what about
those students that are far away from
their family and their friends and like
that's easier because my family makes me
cry yeah so the fact that I was living
on campus yeah your family's bad they've
made it easier for it was easier for me
to deal with my school rather than so
when I was going to evac I would go to
school and I'll come home and get a big
ass fight with my dad like every single
day and that was really hard on my
studies yeah you know a verge like its
perspective like I remember when my dad
like like he beat me right and then he
was like yelling at me and I was a kid
and I started crying and then my mom
came into my room she sat next to me on
my bed and she put her hand on my
shoulder she goes hey don't be a [ __ ]
little [ __ ] cry like that not even
kidding my dad he would come home he'd
come in the room and I needed a crack
closet cuz he was like listen son I want
you to know so [ __ ] proud of you
[ __ ] best like god this is hard to me
like I wanted to cry on the open like
this
yeah what is that like how does that
feel like it's pretty great actually
yeah the last time that I cried though
it was with you guys in Florida we were
playing that VR NASCAR game or whatever
and I was bumping into Geo so [ __ ]
hard the whole game and I was ramming
into Tift the whole game and I was
ramming into you the whole game well I
couldn't catch you cuz you're too fast
he actually played the game loser
doob but I was crying laughing because
the the game makes you like jerk around
yeah it's like VR like this it makes you
dizzy as you're on a race car seat and
then like if you get hit or whatever you
actually feel like [ __ ]
feels and it feels I get it doesn't
steering and your brain is tricked you
actually think you're in the game it's
pretty sick every time I was hitting G
like like I could feel it I know she
told it like it like going out and you
we didn't know there was no names in the
cars but as soon as I started like as
soon as I hit G oh and then I just kept
ramming into jail that constantly she
was like [ __ ] it Steve [ __ ] you yeah
because you knew was me Steve yeah
immediately the last time I cried from
laughter is when this fool
misinterpreted somebody's Vedas oh yeah
I cry from laughter on a trip so with a
couple of guy and his girlfriend but
they thought that it was a two dudes in
a teacup there you know Lucky's only
because her arm was huge like a man so I
was like [ __ ] Bluff so I was like oh
that's cool like he's comfortable enough
to be like you know two middle-aged
dudes in a teacup ride that's what I
thought it was two girls no no it was
like him in his goof oh I see but she
was like the same size yeah I thought it
was his homie and then right when they
said it was a lady like the image
changed yeah could not stop laughing I'm
screwed
yeah that happens here
[Music]